[Musique]
bonjour Jean-Noël barreau bonjour le
réseau social Twitter a décidé de
quitter le code européen de bonnes
pratiques contre la désinformation en
ligne c'est un texte qui est signé par
les grands réseaux sociaux Facebook
Twitter etc des professionnels de la
publicité des fake shaker qui sont gaz
sur une base volontaire à mieux lutter
ensemble contre la désinformation
Twitter donc il s'en extrait quelle est
la réaction officielle de la France du
gouvernement français la désinformation
c'est une des menaces les plus lourdes
qui pèse sur notre démocratie c'est
clair les ennemis de la démocratie
dévoient la liberté d'expression pour un
stylet le mensonge comme un poison dans
le débat public on l'a vu au Capitole on
l'a vu aux États-Unis prix d'assaut par
des partisans de Donald Trump qui
refusaient le résultat de l'élection
absolument la vue avec les antivax
également et c'est la raison pour
laquelle l'Europe a décidé d'un code de
pratique
contre la désinformation c'est 128
mesures qui ont été adoptées sur une
base volontaire par 34 géants du
numérique parmi lesquels Facebook Google
Microsoft et TW mais à côté de ce code
de pratique qui est une qui est une
décision volontaire il y a une règle qui
va s'appliquer à partir du 25 août
prochain et qui oblige les grandes
plateformes de réseaux sociaux à lutter
activement contre la désinformation ce
que je dis Elon Musk c'est pas que la
désinformation de rien il dit que ce
code est superfétatoire qu'il est-il
utile il dit j'ai ma communauté qui est
capable de faire de la lutte contre les
informations en ligne bien écoutez moi
je souhaite que Twitter puisse se
conformer d'ici le 25 août aux règles
européennes nouvelles que nous avons
adoptées sinon il ne sera plus le
bienvenu en Europe et force restera la
loi c'est quoi les règles précisément
qui vont s'appliquer dès la fin de l'été
en Europe
justement dès la fin de l'été c'est un
ensemble de règles qui va s'imposer aux
réseaux sociaux et aux places de marché
qui va les faire rentrer dans l'air de
la responsabilité avec des obligations
de modération c'est à dire de retrait
des contenus illicites qui leur sont
signalés avec des interdictions comme
celle de faire de la publicité ciblée
sur les mineurs par exemple mais aussi
avec une obligation impérieuse celle de
lutter activement contre la
désinformation et il faudra en faire la
preuve sans quoi des amendes très
lourdes pourront être prononcées et puis
en cas de récidive une interdiction
d'activité dans l'Union européenne si
Twitter ne s'y conforme pas il ne sera
plus le bienvenu en Europe l'Europe de
couper Twitter en Europe absolument et
force restera la loi peut être banni de
l'espace européen Twitter s'il ne se
conforme pas à nos règles sera bannie en
cas de récidive de l'Union européenne je
précise que les règles prévoient des
amendes qui peuvent monter jusqu'à 6% du
chiffre d'affaires mondial des
entreprises on imagine donc que pour
Twitter ou Facebook c'est à peu près 300
millions d'euros pour Twitter c'est sur
Twitter tire breton d'ailleurs a réagi
Twitter devenu indispensable y compris
au monde politique
Twitter joue un rôle important dans le
débat public mais nous ne pouvons pas
prendre le risque qu'un réseau social
tel que Twitter se laisse prendre en
otage par les partisans de l'un des
informations et que par conséquent notre
débat public notre démocratie soit
affectée c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons établi des règles claires et
il faudra que tu Twitter s'y confort les
réseaux sociaux sont devenus des sortes
d'organes de presse presque il faut les
considérer presque comme tel les organes
de presse sont assujettis à un régime de
responsabilité très lourd vous le savez
un organe de presse doit disposer d'un
directeur de la publication qui est tenu
responsable pénalement responsable des
contenus qui sont diffusés par ces
journaux par ces médias jusqu'à présent
les réseaux sociaux n'étaient assujettis
à aucune obligation avec un règlement
que la France apportée l'année dernière
sous l'impulsion du Président de la
République et bien nous allons changer
les choses et nous allons faire rentrer
les réseaux sociaux dans une aire de
responsabilité où on peut leur demander
d'être responsable de tous les messages
qui circulent sur leur plateforme ça
serait ça serait vain et ça serait une
atteinte à la liberté d'expression mais
en revanche on va leur demander de
prendre un certain nombre de mesures de
mettre en place un certain nombre de
garde-fous pour que les contenus
illicitent qui transitent sur un
plateforme soit retiré dans les plus
brefs délais et pour que la
désinformation ne puisse pas y prospérer
est-ce que vous dites la même chose à
chaque GPT quatre Twitter si vous ne
vous conformez pas à nos règles vous
n'êtes plus les bienvenus en Europe je
vous dis ça parce que ça malt man le
patron de chat GPT qui était en tournée
européenne c'est inquiété d'une
régulation trop contraignante qui
pourrait arriver dans l'Union européenne
disant bon bah dans ce cas là nous on
n'opéra plus en Europe il est un peu
revenu sur ses propos lors de l'étape
parisienne la double visite de Sam
Altman le fondateur de chat GPT en
France la semaine dernière les propos
qu'il a tenus témoignent de tous les
atouts dont dispose la France dans cette
course effrénée à l'intelligence
artificielle génétique une course dans
laquelle nous devons pas nous laisser
distancer c'est une question de
souveraineté et par ailleurs nous en
avons les moyens pour protéger
l'innovation pour cela il faut investir
et le président de la République aura
l'occasion de faire des annonces dans
quelques semaines et il faut réguler
efficacement et intelligemment il y a
quelque chose qui s'est passé il y a
quelques jours et qui est très
intéressant c'est que Google a lancé à
son tour son propre chat GPT qui
s'appelle Bard il l'a lancé dans 180
pays autour du monde mais pas en Europe
sauf en Europe en raison d'une risque de
réglementaire en tout cas c'est ce que
Google en fait c'est la protection des
données c'est le fameux rgpd alors il
est vrai que l'Europe et la première
démocratie du monde à avoir décidé de se
doter d'un cadre pour l'intelligence
artificielle c'est ce qu'on appelle le
règlement
Ia le règlement sur l'intelligence
artificielle
mais je considère que à ce stade la
position que le Parlement européen a
pris sur le règlement sur l'intelligence
artificielle est excessive et risque de
faire sortir
il est impératif c'est une ardente
obligation il est impératif pour nous de
disposer dans les mois qui viennent de
modèles tels que ceux qui ont développé
ces géants américains
vous dites elle est peut-être excessive
sur quel point de vue elle est peut-être
elle est je dis qu'à ce stade la
position du Parlement européen est
excessive car elle impose des
obligations d'audit des obligations de
transparence qui sont excessives pour ce
type de modèle le type de modèle comme
chat GPT qui font l'objet d'une course
effrénée dans laquelle nous ne devons
pas nous laisser distancer sans quoi
nous nous enfermerions dans des
décennies d'assujettissement et de
dépendance technologique il faut que
nous restions dans la course il faut
évidemment donner un cadre au
développement de l'intelligence
artificielle mais à ce stade la position
du Parlement européen est excessive
ce qu'on a fait jusqu'ici en régulant
cette favoriser les grands groupes
américains qui eux ont une batterie
juriste pour contourner les règlements
et puis finalement on a tué l'innovation
européenne
je pense que la régulation est
nécessaire on parlait tout à l'heure des
réseaux sociaux et je me félicite de
l'adoption l'année dernière de deux
règlements majeurs à l'initiative de la
France et du président de la République
qui mettent de l'ordre dans l'économie
numérique et dans la société numérique
il s'agissant de l'intelligence
artificielle qui est une technologie
émergente il est impératif que nous
puissions encadrer mais avant cela que
nous puissions nous doter de ces outils
là sans quoi nous serons dépendants des
outils produits ailleurs les Américains
continueront de développer leur modèle
aux États-Unis
les Français parmi les meilleurs du
monde iront probablement aux États-Unis
développer leur propre modèle je
souhaite que nous disposions dans les
prochains mois de ce type de modèle pour
conserver notre souveraineté et notre
autonomie stratégique dans les domaines
civils et militaires car les
applications telles que chat GPT auront
des applications dans les deux
dimensions vous allez citer que les
États-Unis je remarque pas la Chine non
plus si la Chine évidemment
parce que c'est aussi les données qui
permettent d'alimenter les intelligences
artificielles et les rendre plus
performantes elles sont très protégées
en Europe elles le sont beaucoup moins
évidemment en Chine journal Barrault
vont rester avec nous ministre délégué à
la transition numérique et aux
télécommunications 8h41 c'est l'heure du
fil info avec Maureen finir le président
américain salut des alliés au sein de
l'OTAN avec le Président erdouane nous
continuerons à avancer complète le chef
d'État français Emmanuel Macron raychet
tape one réélu président de la Turquie
avec plus de 52% des voix après déjà 20
ans passés au pouvoir faut-il fixer des
taux de recyclage obligatoire au pays
faire payer davantage les pollueurs
payeurs ou même interdire certains
plastiques des mesures en discussion à
Paris les négociateurs représentant 175
états sont réunis pour mettre fin à la
pollution plastique dans le monde
l'objectif est de sceller un accord
d'ici deux ans le parquet de Lorient
indique procédé à des vérifications un
homme est en garde à vue ce trentenaire
est un proche d'une femme retrouvée
morte ce week-end le corps de cette
femme repêchée dans une rivière dans le
Morbihan du monde dès le milieu de
matinée sur les routes pour cette fin de
weekend de la Pentecôte c'est orange
dans le sens des retours dans le grand
Ouest le nord et l'Île-de-France
France Info
le 8 30 France Info mais il a la trousse
Laurent Sénéchal toujours avec Jean-Noël
Barrault ministre délégué à la
transition numérique et aux
télécommunications on parlait tout à
l'heure dès le musk le patron de Twitter
il apporte aussi le milliardaire
américain une aide considérable à
l'Ukraine dans la guerre contre la
Russie via son réseau Internet Starling
réseau par satellite il a menacé
plusieurs fois de le couper puisqu'il a
de musk il est aussi proche de la droite
américaine et donc indirectement de la
Russie c'est un acteur privé qui a trop
de pouvoir finalement
c'est un opérateur de satellite il en
existe d'autres et en particulier
l'opérateur français Orange dispose d'un
opérateur de satellite et à aujourd'hui
trois quatre fois plus de clients que
Starling sur notre pays dans notre pays
même même si ça n'est pas toujours un
chiffre connu je crois que il nous faut
pouvoir disposer de constellations
souveraines et c'est la raison pour
laquelle la France a soutenu
l'initiative européenne iris au carré
iris II qui va nous permettre de
disposer de cette autonomie là
s'agissait des réseaux de
télécommunication il faut à la fois
pouvoir disposer de la couverture mobile
et fixe avec la fibre mais aussi veiller
à ce que nous soyons couverts par les
constellations de satellite et ce sera à
quelle échéance alors que l'Europe
pourrait déployer sa propre
constellation de satellite pour envoyer
internet sur le plancher des vaches
c'est dans la décennie qui vient mais je
le rappelle il existe d'ores et déjà des
offres satellites auprès de votre
opérateur en tout cas si vous êtes chez
Orange donc en quelque sorte nous
n'avons rien envie à Orange si l'on
prend à la fois le projet européen et
les offres déjà existantes sur le tarif
ça veut dire que c'est pas tout de suite
qu'on va se substituer à Starling pour
aider les Ukrainiens on a aidé les
Ukrainiens à bien des égards et
notamment en matière de
télécommunication à certains nombre
d'opérateurs se sont mobilisés pour
apporter des solutions et de l'expertise
c'est il faut reconnaître à Elon Musk
d'avoir agi très vite pour pouvoir
donner à la fois à la population
Ukraine mais aussi surtout à l'armée des
moyens de communiquer mais nous ne
sommes pas en reste et là aussi à
l'initiative du Président de la
République beaucoup a été fait y compris
en matière de télécommunication dernière
chose sur ce sujet c'est aussi un moyen
de lutter contre les zones blanches en
France puisque vous citez orange le fait
d'avoir un réseau satellitaire internet
l'objectif qui est le nôtre c'est de
couvrir avec les réseaux mobiles
l'intégralité du territoire mais aussi
de le faire avec le très haut débit et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
travaillons activement au déploiement de
la fibre nous sommes bien avancés
puisque la France est le pays d'Europe
qui est le mieux fibré ceci étant dit il
restera toujours quelques quelques
territoires quelques locaux d'habitation
qui sont si éloignés des centres-villes
des centres bourgs qu'il faudra bien
trouver une solution alternative à la
fibre et dès lors le satellite s'y
prêtera Jean-Noël barreau j'aimerais que
l'on revienne à l'instant sur les
réseaux sociaux avec dans l'actualité se
suicide atroce la jeune Lindsey il y a
deux semaines 13 ans elle était
scolarisée dans un collège du
Pas-de-Calais ses parents expliquent
qu'elle était la cible d'insultes à
répétition à l'école et sur les réseaux
sociaux depuis la rentrée quelle
responsabilité de ces réseaux dans le
cyber-harcèlement c'est un drame qu'on a
comme on en a connu beaucoup trop
souvent ces dernières années j'ai
évidemment une pensée pour la famille et
ce drame il nous invite à continuer
d'agir et de et d'accélérer pour faire
reculer le cyber-harcèlement en ligne
qui touche les enfants vous l'avez dit
qui touchent aussi les femmes les femmes
en 27 fois plus de chances
de malchances de subir le
cyber-harcèlement sur internet que les
hommes et face à cela il nous faut je
dirais une approche à 360 degrés il nous
faut travailler à la sensibilisation et
à la sensibilisation des élèves dès la
rentrée prochaine tous les élèves de 6e
dans notre pays se verront dispenser un
passeport numérique c'est-à-dire un
module de sensibilisation en salle
informatique donc c'est un cours de
Twitter et de Facebook les éduquera au
risque et aux bonnes attitudes à adopter
en ligne lorsque l'on est témoin ou
victime de cyber-harcèlement la loi de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur portée par Gérald Darmanin
la loi de programmation la justice
portée par Eric Dupont-Moretti vont là
aussi ajouter des moyens dont je
souhaite qu'il puisse être orienté vers
la prise des plaintes l'instruction et
les enquêtes de ces faits de cyber ça
prend du temps
c'est ce qu'on voit dans le cadre de
l'Insee le harcèlement a été caractérisé
a été remontée à l'établissement et
pourtant le temps de le faire cesser
cette jeune fille passe à l'acte
absolument et ça ça suppose une
sensibilisation beaucoup plus forte des
enfants c'est l'objectif de ce passeport
numérique qui sera généralisé qui est
expérimenté actuellement qui sera
généralisée à la rentrée prochaine mais
il faut aussi vous dites faut bannir
aussi les séparres solaires des
plateformes je dis qu'effectivement et
ça fait partie des propositions que je
porte dans un projet de loi qui sera
examiné cet été qu'il faut bannir comme
on le fait avec l'interdiction de stade
pour les hooligans celles et ceux qui a
répétition ce livre à des à des actions
de cybarcellement qui propagent la haine
sur les réseaux sociaux qui embrasse
leur communauté c'est un juge qui décide
ou c'est le réseau social qui est le
juge dès lors qu'il aura prononcé une
condamnation à l'encontre d'une personne
qui se sera rendu coupable de
cyber-harcèlement comme les agresseurs
de Mila ou les agresseurs de dédit de
Pretto et bien le juge pourra prononcer
une peine complémentaire de bannissement
à l'image de la peine complémentaire
d'interdiction encore une fois c'est pas
quelque chose qui se fera dans l'urgence
donc ça veut dire que il y aura eu un
procès c'est la raison pour laquelle je
plaide pour une approche à 360° qui va
de la sensibilisation à la sanction et
qui touche toutes les générations parce
que le cyber-harcèlement n'est pas le
juge français pourra décider pour ces
plateformes qui sont souvent américaines
notamment ou chinoises
du bannissement le juge donnera
l'obligation à ces plateformes de mettre
tout en oeuvre pour interdire la
réinscription des auteurs de
cyber-harcèlement sur leur place parce
qu'elle se cache souvent derrière des
lois californiennes par exemple qui sont
plus protectrices de la liberté
d'expression en France les plateformes
appliquent le droit français et en
Europe elles appliquent le droit
européen on disait que ça touchait
toutes les générations chiffres de la
CNIL la Commission nationale de
l'informatique et des libertés la
première inscription à un réseau social
en France intervient en moyenne vers 8
ans et demi ces jeunes c'est très jeune
c'est beaucoup trop jeune sachant que
ces plateformes ont fixées en général
l'âge de 13 ans comme étant l'âge
minimum pour s'inscrire sur ces
plateformes c'est-à-dire qu'elle ne
vérifie pas et je veux saluer
l'initiative parlementaire de Laurent
Marc Angelli qui que j'ai soutenu qui
vient d'être adopté à l'humour
et du Sénat et qui vient imposer à ces
plateformes de vérifier l'âge des
enfants et des utilisateurs lorsqu'ils
s'inscrivent mais aussi
de recueillir le consentement des
parents parce qu'avant 15 ans il faudra
une autorisation parentale il faudra
l'autorisation parentale et c'est euh
c'est une étape qui est franchie dans la
bonne direction pour la pour la
protection des mineurs en ligne c'est
c'est dans les mois qui viennent que
cette obligation nouvelle s'appliquera
et on va travailler maintenant que la
loi va la loi est adoptée ou presque
pour mettre en œuvre les mesures pour y
parvenir
si les enfants peuvent s'inscrire mais
aussi s'il les enfants doivent sortir de
des réseaux sociaux ils pourront
demander j'ai cru voir que c'est les
parlementaires qui ont ajouté ça au
texte demandez la suspension du compte
d'un enfant de moins de 15 ans
absolument c'est ce qu'on appelle la
majorité numérique avant 15 ans on a le
droit de s'inscrire sur un réseau social
ou d'en sortir mais avec l'autorisation
et ça va se passer comment concrètement
l'adolescence sera en ligne on va lui
demander une photo de sa carte
d'identité on va lui demander une
signature numérique de ses parents vous
le savez pour la la protection des
enfants en ligne que ce soit sur la
question des réseaux sociaux ou de
l'exposition à la pornographie en en
dira peut-être un mot la mère des
batailles c'est la vérification d'âge
cela fait deux ans que nous y
travaillons sur la question de
l'exposition au contenu pornographique
des solutions existent déjà elles sont
imparfaites mais elles existent et donc
les plateformes les sites
pornographiques pourraient sans saisir
j'ai incité un certain nombre
d'entreprises françaises à développer
des solutions qui soient à la fois
fiables sur la mesure de l'âge de
l'utilisateur et qui garantissent zéro
fichage 0 piratage pour que à l'avenir
nous puissions disposer d'outils de
vérification d'âge en ligne qui soit
parfaitement adéquat et accepté
justement on va parler de ce fléau de la
pornographie chez nos adolescents dans
un tout petit instant avec vous
Jean-Noël Barrault ministre délégué en
charge de la transition numérique et des
télécommunications Maurice fignard 8h50
selfie l'info
37 missiles 29 drones russes c'est ce
que l'armée ukrainienne dit avoir abattu
pendant la nuit
troisième attaque de ce type en Ukraine
depuis le début du mois la réélection du
président herdohann saluait dans le
monde celui qui est à la tête du pouvoir
turc depuis 20 ans remporte la
présidentielle avec plus de 52% des voix
et signe pour 5 ans supplémentaires sont
rival le social-démocrate qui est mal
Kelly a exprimé sa tristesse face aux
difficultés dit-il qui attendent le pays
un blessé par balle à Marseille la nuit
dernière dans le 14e arrondissement de
la ville la victime est âgée de 32 ans
il était chez lui quand de faux livreurs
de pizza se sont présentés et lui ont
tiré dessus il vient pour gagner le cerf
Novak Djokovic débute Roland Garros
aujourd'hui tout comme le numéro 1
mondial l'Espagnol Carlos alcara si
français aussi à l'affiche aujourd'hui
donc Caroline Garcia Benoît Paire et
Arthur fils hier c'est Lucas Pouille
notamment qui a signé un exploit en se
qualifiant pour le second tour après une
traversée du désert
France Info
le 8 30 France Info mais il a la trousse
le rincenéchal la question de la
majorité numérique qui se pose pour
l'accès aux réseaux sociaux et aussi au
site pornographique l'arcom la semaine
dernière révélé ses chiffres un tiers
des moins de 18 ans consultent chaque
mois au moins un site porno proportions
encore plus effrayante chez les 12-13
ans un garçon sur deux à cet âge
consulte ses sites chaque mois ça veut
dire que toutes les mesures qui ont été
prises jusqu'ici avec depuis 1992 une
infraction qui existe sur l'exposition
des mineurs à ces images à caractère
sexuel toutes les mesures prises
n'empêche pas les mineurs d'accéder à du
contenu pornographique
la situation était connue mais les
chiffres publiés par l'art comme sont
terrifiants par leur ampleur 2 millions
d'enfants exposés chaque mois aussi de
pornographique par leur progression plus
40% en 5 ans et par la précocité du
phénomène vous l'avez rappelé dès 12 ans
un garçon sur deux est exposé chaque
mois à des images pornographiques
pourquoi parce que les sites ne
vérifient pas l'âge de leurs
utilisateurs la majorité de leurs
utilisateurs alors même qu'ils y sont
tenus par la loi ils disent on n'a pas
les moyens techniques de le faire ils
disent qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens
techniques pour le faire ils nous disent
qu'ils ne peuvent pas mais en réalité
ils le peuvent mais ils ne veulent pas
pourquoi parce que ces sites qui sont
gratuits et qui déversent des contenus
en libre accès sur Internet vivent de la
publicité et notamment celle générée par
le trafic par les visites des mineurs
qui représentent 10 à 20% de leur
recette ils exploitent les légumes
recèle ni plus ni moins et ça doit
cesser alors il est vrai qu'il y a deux
ans une loi a été prise qui impose aussi
de pornographique de vérifier l'âge de
leurs utilisateurs
est en cours
concernant les cinq sites
pornographiques principaux dans notre
pays le verdict sera rendu le 7 juillet
je souhaite qu'il soit exemplaire et
pour l'avenir je propose que nous
donnions à l'arcome le pouvoir de
bloquer et de des référencer sur les
moteurs de recherche les sites
pornographiques qui ne vérifieront pas
l'âge de leurs utilisateurs ce sera la
manière comme quelques semaines je
précise pour nos auditeurs absolument ça
sera la manière de donner à l'arcom le
moyen de bloquer en quelques semaines
les sites pornographiques qui se
conformeront pas alors obligation alors
qu'aujourd'hui et bien ils ont fait
traîner les choses devant la justice et
que cette situation est tout à fait
inaccepte exemplaire en justice c'est
quoi c'est l'interdiction par exemple de
ces sites c'est le blocage et le des
référencement aujourd'hui c'est le juge
qui peut prononcer cette peine à l'issue
d'une procédure judiciaire je propose
pour aller plus vite et mettre à ce
phénomène dramatique qui emporte des
conséquences très lourdes sur la santé
de nos enfants troubles de
l'alimentation du sommeil de l'attention
développement de conduite à risque de
conduite violente et bien tout cela doit
cesser et c'est la raison pour laquelle
lorsque le projet de loi que je porte et
qui sera examiné au mois de juillet aura
été adopté l'art comme oral pouvoir en
quelques semaines de bloquer les sites
qui ne vérifieront pas encore une fois
l'outil que vous voulez mettre en place
parce qu'on a beaucoup parlé par exemple
de une empreinte de carte bleue pour
essayer de l'empreinte de carte bleue
est une solution imparfaite à bien des
égards mais elle existe et il appartient
au site pornographique de la mettre en
place dès aujourd'hui pour faire cesser
la situation ce serait mieux que rien ça
serait mieux que rien mais je souhaite
pour l'avenir et parce que vous l'avez
compris la vérification d'âge est un
sujet pour les sites pornographiques
mais elle l'est aussi pour les réseaux
sociaux et en réalité tous les services
sur Internet dont nous voulons protéger
nos enfants et bien c'est les c'est pour
cela que j'ai demandé à des entreprises
de réfléchir au développement de
solutions de vérification d'âge qui soit
à la fois fiable et à la fois
robuste et qui garantissent zéro fichage
et zéro piratage c'est-à-dire ça
pourrait être un tiers de confiance
comme par exemple pour toute le public
en France Connect qu'on utilise pour
aller sur tout un tas de sites
différents et qui authentifient qui est
la personne derrière son ordinateur on
se connecte c'est qui vous êtes et donc
on peut pas lui demander directement de
d'authentifier votre âge mais ce que
l'on peut faire c'est avoir des
applications qui vont recueillir de la
part de fournisseurs d'identité
numérique peut-être qu'un jour France
Connect en fera partie une preuve
anonyme de votre âge ou de votre
majorité libre à vous de l'utiliser
ensuite pour accéder à des services sur
Internet et la même manière que lorsque
aujourd'hui nous effectuons un paiement
sur internet et que l'application de
notre banque nous demande une
vérification à partir de notre
smartphone on peut très bien imaginer
que notre preuve anonyme de majorité
soit stockée sur une application
sollicité par les services réservés aux
adultes ou limiter pour un certain âge
lorsque nous voulons y accéder puisque
vous évoquez les smartphones c'est
essentiellement le moyen par lequel ces
jeunes publics accèdent à ces sites
pornographiques quel rôle pour les
opérateurs télécoms est-ce que ça peut
être eux le tiers de confiance est-ce
qu'on peut imaginer par exemple des
forfaits spécifiques pour les mineurs et
l'opérateur télécom qui dira attention
vous êtes face à un mineur ou majeur il
me semble que certains forfaits existent
déjà mais en tout état de cause la
sanction elle le banniss le pardon le
blocage repose évidemment sur les
fournisseurs d'accès à Internet
c'est-à-dire sur les opérateurs télécoms
lorsque l'arcom une fois mon projet de
loi adopté prononcera ou ordonnera le
blocage des des sites pornographiques
concernés c'est bien les opérateurs
télécoms qui effectueront ce blocage je
voudrais le barreau l'actualité de votre
secteur ne fait parfois basculer dans ce
qui ressemble ou ce qui ressemblait
encore quelques années à de la
science-fiction d'évoquer l'un de Mesk
tout à l'heure l'une de ces entreprises
neuralink va pouvoir commencer des
essais cliniques sur des humains alors
quelles essais cliniques des implants
placés dans le cerveau pour pouvoir
contrôler les ordinateurs par la pensée
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire est-ce que
ça vous intrigue est-ce que ça vous
fatigue est-ce que ça vous inquiète
d'abord permettez-moi de rappeler que
c'est le même Elon Musk qu'il y a
quelques semaines signé un moratoire sur
l'intelligence artificielle pour dire
c'est tout cela ensuite permettez-moi de
saluer la prouesse scientifique des
chercheurs du CEA et de l'école fédérale
polytechnique de Lausanne qui viennent
français et suisses de français et
suisses qui viennent de permettre à un
homme paraplégique de 40 ans de
retrouver l'usage de ses jambes grâce au
numérique et à l'intelligence
artificielle
en l'occurrence et c'est simplement ma
colonne vertébrale mais un boîtier
extérieur et c'est une très belle
illustration de toutes les promesses de
l'intelligence artificielle pour nous
permettre de sortir des impasses
thérapeutiques et de permettre de
trouver une solution à des personnes qui
avaient perdu tout espoir de guérison
mais s'agissant du projet transhumaniste
d'Elon musk le projet d'homme augmenté
ça n'est pas le mien ça n'est pas le
nôtre et en tout état de cause le cadre
bioéthique que nous avons en France si
opposera Jean-Noël barreau merci
beaucoup
ministre délégué chargé de la transition
numérique très cher nail à la trousse
bon vent et à tous et toutes bonne
journée
[Musique]